- [Interviewer] All right, Beautiful.
Beautiful, where did you
grow up, where are you from?
- Kingston, Jamaica.
- You're from Jamaica?
- Yes.
- Oh wow.
And you came to the US at what age?
- Five years old.
- At five years old?
- At five.
- And tell me about your childhood.
Did you have both your parents?
- Yes.
- How was life with your folks?
- Different.
My mom was great,
and my father turned out to be a pastor,
but he fell by the wayside
maybe somewhere along the way.
I was eight years old.
I don't know what happened,
but the people say that they
put a curse on my family.
And my dad ended up molesting me
from about eight years old to,
I was about 13.
- Oh my god.
- And my mom leave him,
and we ended up with my stepfather,
so we came to the United States.
They gave us clearance to
come to the United States.
We moved to New Jersey.
She wasn't working out there,
so we moved to Dayton, Ohio.
From that point,
I was maybe 14.
We had our handicapped sister,
so I stayed home most of the time.
Do home studies
and help my mother.
She met a new gentleman,
things went from there.
I was
always kind of a good but bad kid.
Like I told you, I'm gifted.
I have different gifts and
it's really weird to have 'em.
People say it's kind of like ESP.
- ESP?
- ESP.
You know, I don't know how,
I still to this day, can't explain it.
But I see things, I feel things,
and I think it's because of
my background and my heritage.
- You'll sense things
that other people won't?
- Oh yeah.
It's scary though.
It caused my mom to kind
of pull away from me.
She dealt with the
other kids more than me.
So I got standoffish.
Pretty much shy.
I fought a lot in school.
Nobody liked me. (laughs)
Seems different now, but
nobody really liked me.
I started prostituting.
I hid it from my mom.
I started having sex.
I had my first baby in high school.
I still graduated though.
And my handicapped sister
died from pneumonia.
And kind of, my mother
lost it a little bit.
She didn't care about us, she'd
spank us, hit us, beat us,
she didn't, she just was done.
I guess, as you could say, as I get older,
I had to get a job.
I had to do whatever it took to survive
and help my mother survive.
Me and my brother are the
only two siblings left now.
Every last one of us are gone.
Father, mother, both sisters.
It's just me and my baby brother now.
I have six beautiful kids
and two grand babies,
but they're still distanced right now.
- Who are they with?
- My two younger ones are
with my kids father's family.
My older ones are all older.
Yeah, so I don't have too
much worry about them,
but they worry about me.
- Did you raise the older ones?
- Yes, for the most part.
- Do you still talk to all (indistinct)?
- Oh definitely, I love my kids.
That's my new release to life, so.
I'm still homeless to this day.
I'm still prostituting.
- But you've had jobs?
- Oh wonderful jobs.
- You've had careers.
- Yes, I worked in real estate.
I actually was a manager
to one of the largest,
it's called the Metro Car Express.
It's one of the largest
car wash exchanges there.
And I was the manager to
one in San Fernando Valley.
So, I kind of got fired
because everybody got fired.
Our boss was stealing money
and they found out about it.
And they kind of got
rid of his whole crew,
everyone he hired, they got rid of us all.
- So you went back to the streets?
- Quickly, because I was
staying with him and his family
and they were Hispanic people.
And without a job you
can't live with them.
They don't want you there,
so they put us all out.
Yeah.
I'm not really sure.
I worked with the police
department, actually, before.
- You did?
- Yeah, it was weird.
I actually helped them solve
a car crash case on 74th
and I believe it's Grand.
A 13-year-old boy was ran over.
They couldn't find the person.
The family was pressing the
police department very hard.
I covered that.
I found the car, I don't
know how, just don't ask me.
It just all worked out.
- You used your empathic skills.
- It worked.
- Yeah.
- The family, they gave me a $1,000.
At the time, they gave me what they could.
So it was a blessing.
I really don't know what to say,
this is my first time ever doing this,
or even telling people this.
So it's kind of weird
and I'm scared to even
be telling people this,
because I don't want a
whole bunch of people like,
"Oh, she does this."
They kind of do it anyways.
A lot of people flock to me.
I don't know if it's others like me
but we all have the same sense.
It's really weird but it's
fun to be around people
who even are interested, you could say.
I have a tent.
They set my tent on fire
with me in it.
It's getting really ugly out there.
- So you're homeless?
- Oh yeah, I'm definitely homeless.
- Oh my god.
I'm working with the county right now
to get into the pilot program.
I don't know if you know about
it but it's a decent program.
They provide vouchers for motel rooms,
but they have a certain time frame.
So when that time frame runs out,
you're just back out on the streets,
until they can get you
situated with housing, so.
You'd have to rely on church
or different agencies
for showers, clothes, and
different things like that.
I try to just work with any and everybody.
Like down here, in downtown,
they've got a lot a businesses.
You can sweep, fold clothes.
I mean, there's things you can do.
So I apply myself in different ways,
so that I can stay productive,
because it's really bad out here
and there's a lot of sickness.
- Yeah.
- And I don't want it. (laughs)
- So working the streets
as a prostitute now,
you're working on your own?
- Yes.
- No pimp.
- Yes, no pimp.
My kids are my pimps.
- Yeah.
- I have to try to make sure I
send them some type of money.
I just, even though my daughter tells me,
"Mom, worry about yourself.
You're outside on the streets,
worry about yourself."
I can't do it.
I gotta do something, 50 bucks,
whatever I can to send to them.
She tries to send it back,
we have this thing on.
But I have beautiful children,
so yeah, being a prostitute
out here is hard.
I've been raped five times or more.
I just had a recent incident.
I believe I was telling you about it.
I was pulled out of a car
and I was held down,
and they were taking a torch
to the side of my body here.
And I mean, I could
show you the burn marks.
- Yeah, you showed me yesterday.
- But they were burning me.
They had no intentions on a date.
It was not even in their mind.
They were there to inflict
pain and they did their job.
I only got away because
a lady at the church
putting on the corner.
For some reason heard me yelling,
she came out, she got me
away from 'em, they took off.
It's hard, nothing's the same out here.
At all.
- Does it get you down?
- Huh?
- You must get depressed
by doing this, right?
- I do, because it's not
something that I choose to do.
It's not something that I like.
I'm not very promiscuous though, so.
To do it is, so,
I can't say it's disgusting
because it's the natural
order is to have sex.
To me it just kind of throws
me in a different frame of mind
because it puts me back with
when I was being raped
or molested by my father,
and then raped.
So then to continue to do this right now,
I'm kinda, I'm leery.
I don't know who to deal
with, when to deal with them.
I try to read people
before I deal with them,
to kinda see where their mindset is.
Sometimes we're still wrong.
You know, I got my face busted open here.
I've still got wires in my jaw.
There's some real tricky
pimps out here now.
They'll come to you as
a date, or whatever,
just to get you in the car.
When you're in the car,
they'll take all your money.
They're gonna rob you.
Then they're gonna show you,
you have one or two options.
You're gonna work for me,
you're gonna get me money
or you're gonna get attacked
every time we see you on the street.
And they do that.
It's a blessing to find different people
who will actually pull you in.
We don't get that very often,
and being women out here,
it's like guys are a 100 to one of us.
And they're gonna press you.
They're gonna beat you up.
They're gonna find a way
to get you on your own.
They're taking advantage
of our vulnerability
to the fullest.
And nobody is saying anything to 'em.
So they feel they can get away with it.
I mean, I'm not a police type person,
but they're like all in
the cloud moving around.
They just drive.
And because they've mentioned
this sickness thing,
everyone's all afraid.
So it's like the police doesn't even wanna
come near anybody.
Well, what if we really need help?
Where are you guys?
Oh, slap on the wrist, go guy.
It's not cool.
Like literally, they burnt my tent up.
If I took this hair piece off,
you'd see my hair was on fire.
I mean, I could show you
some really crazy crap.
You'd be like, "What the fuck,
are you guys outside for?"
You know, so excuse me for
cursing, but yeah, I was burnt.
It's not a good feeling.
- No.
- I'm not happy.
Now that I met our friend Kabul,
I can sleep in his car every
now and again for safety.
He goes in, and he has
people he can go inside with,
so I utilize the car.
Any means I can to get safe, I use it.
The churches don't open to us
anymore, so that's a no, no.
You can get a shower, excuse
me, some food, that's about it.
- Are drugs a part of your life?
- Drug programs.
- And do you use?
- No, that's the problem with me.
And they're testing
people now on the way in.
So if you're not dirty,
they don't want you.
I found a transitional, a
couple of transitional homes.
Susan Burton, it's
called, A New Way of Life.
She accepts anybody, but she's so full.
Like every one of her
houses and she's got 16.
- Wow.
- And they're all full.
So, if I could find more
places like hers, I'd be okay.
- Do you feel like what
happened to you and your father
when you were eight years
old, kind of opened the door
for you to do it when you were younger,
and then again now when
you got more desperate?
- I do and it's not a
good feeling sometimes.
When I'm doin' it, I feel dirty.
And if anybody approaches
me that looks like my dad,
I'm just freaked out.
I feel like I'm being haunted.
Like, I literally freak out.
I'm like, "Where'd you come from?"
I feel like either you're
tryin' to apologize to me,
but then these people are comin' at me
asking for the same thing he took from me.
So, I'm just like, this is really weird,
and I'm just like no, I won't do it.
I'm just like, I can't.
I don't want to deal with anybody.
You know, if I find
someone that looks him,
I shell off, big time.
That hurt me more than anything,
because my dad was my best friend.
Like literally, I'd ride
on my dad's shoulders.
We'd sing, we'd dance, we do music.
You know, that was my best friend.
So everything else was like wow, you know.
And they're robbing us blind out here.
There's just nothing, we're
getting robbed blind, you know.
There's no one that cares.
And like, I can sing,
I can dance, I have other qualities,
but at 43 years old,
most people look at me
like I'm a little kid.
Where that comes from, I have no clue.
But most people view me as a child.
I get that everywhere.
I don't know where that comes from.
I know I look pretty young
for my age, I get it.
Tomorrow's my birthday and I
have no clue what I'm gonna do.
- Happy birthday.
- Thank you.
- Do you have any friends?
- No. Kabul.
And I met him on a humbug.
- What is humbug?
- He almost ran me over.
(Interviewer and Beautiful laugh)
- What is humbug?
- Like, just on a fluke.
- Oh, I see.
- Yeah.
- He almost ran me over and
he's felt bad ever since.
So like every time he sees me, he's like,
"Do you need any food?"
"Can I get you?"
And I'm just like, "You
don't have to do that."
But now, we kinda got a
little friendship thing where,
like I said, I can sleep in the car.
He goes into the house with whoever.
You know, he has family out here, I don't.
So for him to even integrate
me into his family,
like the girl he was with
today, is his sister.
I got to meet her.
She let me sleep on her floor last night.
So I got to sleep inside a house, finally,
after almost about seven months.
So, yeah, I got take a real bath.
You know what I mean?
Those things you cherish.
After you haven't had 'em for awhile,
you get 'em again, you cherish them.
- What's the most important
lesson you've learned
from the rough life you've had?
- Oh, to temper my mouth.
Because I have a real
live Jamaican attitude
and we're pop off, real fast type people.
We don't take no crap.
So,
for me,
to deal with how these American people do,
I have to seal my mouth.
I have to observe every situation
and I can't allow anything,
I'm getting goosebumps.
I can't allow anything
to get me to that point,
because I'll probably die.
'Cause I'm really hotheaded.
So like this lady gave me her name,
and I told her to stuff that
no one has no consideration.
There's no respect.
There's no boundaries no more.
I feel like we're in Sodom
and Gomorrah right now.
I see sex, drugs, killing,
whoever it get, you know.
May the best girl or
guy stand up, you know,
like it's, come on,
I feel like I'm in a
gladiator movie right now.
It's like non-stop.
Like you said,
you've got one on this, and one on this,
and you got guys to do it, breath.
Ask me, can you help clean the studio.
I mean, integrate.
Bring something else out of your self.
There's nothing there, nobody gets it.
It's like is there anything
that you guys see besides green?
They don't, baby.
- Yeah.
- It's really sad.
It's the only thing they see is green.
And if you got it, you're cool.
If you don't, they yell at ya.
You got what I'm sayin'?
And you can really see that out here.
Right in front of us.
- Yep.
- It's crazy.
- All right, Beautiful,
well thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Thank you.
- And good luck with
wherever you go from here.
- Thank you very much.
- I hope you get a job and
get your life together.
- I'm glad to come.
- Get off the street.
- Yes, sir.
- Thank you.